hoy conversamos con uno de los ganadores
del premio medioambiental goldman 2022 o
álex el visitante quien se lo ganó junto
al ex anda a alexandra narváez por el
presidente legal que su comunidad sentó
en ecuador contra las prácticas
extractivas del oro ellos se definen
como los guardianes de la naturaleza que
ven amenazada su supervivencia según
ellos el día en que los territorios
indígenas lleguen a desaparecer también
lo harán ellos a inicios de este 2022 la
corte constitucional de ecuador respaldó
en un fallo que sentó jurisprudencia en
el derecho de los pueblos indígenas a
decidir sobre sus territorios en el
conocido caso como sin angol tras la
demanda de la nacionalidad indígena aiko
fna por no haber sido consultada sobre
decenas de concesiones mineras en sus
territorios ancestrales los cofanes son
un pueblo indígena compuesto por 1.200
personas y su cultura está profundamente
arraigada en la tierra los ríos los
bosques que también constituyen todo su
entorno y dependen de la agricultura
para la subsistencia a la casa y también
la recolección silvestre es la cuarta
vez que el goldman recae en ecuador para
ello entonces quiero saludar a uno de
nuestros invitados del día álex el
visitante es defensor de los derechos
humanos activista en defensa derechos de
la naturaleza y territorios ancestrales
de la comunidad con funk y también
alecsandro narváez sería presidente de
la asociación de mujeres de meco guardia
y defensora de la selva de la comunidad
sinagoga álex alexandra gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francia 24 felicidades además por este
reconocimiento del premio goldman como
ustedes lo reciben y qué responsabilidad
también le está a hacer acreedores de
este premio para seguir con su lucha
no sé si empezamos con álex
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
entrevista en recintos médicos es un
gusto para nosotros poder compartir
nuestra experiencia nuestra lucha desde
los territorios está el reconocimiento
del premio ambiental goldman es un
reconocimiento a una lucha colectiva
desde la comunidad con fans y nadie
estamos una comunidad bastante pequeña
en la provincia de sucumbíos
en ecuador
nuestros territorios se encontraban
amenazados y puesto que la comunidad
decidió defender ante la amenaza de las
minerías que el estado ecuatoriano salvó
entonces si es
eso lo que
la lucha que la comunidad sin angüés
dijo con resultados bastante importantes
a nivel judicial e inspiró a otras
comunidades a ayudar procesos de defensa
del territorio y este reconocimiento es
como
es cómo reconocer ese trabajo la fuerza
que la comunidad ha brindado ha tenido
para poder como seguir adelante
con este proceso de prensa y finalmente
la vida sin agua hubo una sentencia
judicial muy importante de la corte
constitucional y creo que también por
toda esta visibilidad al nivel de
ecuador es lo que nos han hecho
gracias al ex alexandra también quiero
empezar a preguntándole usted cómo
recibe este premio y también como esto
confirma y también refuerzan su lucha
con sus tierras con el medio ambiente
buenos días a todos esto de estar aquí
para compartir
en el
debate
para nuestro
reconocimiento del volcán ha sido un
reconocimiento
fuerza de nuestra unión
es un presas
entonces ese premio para nosotros ha
sido
la esperanza también porque
con este reconocimiento a la misma gente
a nuestra luz
alexandra qué pena la tengo que la tengo
que interrumpir lamentablemente porque
tenemos un uso de problemas de
comunicación entiendo por el internet
pues que no nos llega tanto a esa zona
donde donde se encuentra al ex y quiero
entonces volver con usted para ver si
recuperamos la conversación y la
conexión para poder escuchar bien a
alexandra cómo es su lucha día a día al
cge
y nosotros nosotros somos una comunidad
una cultura milenaria y en amazonía
ecuatoriana
nuestros abuelos han vivido de estos
territorios y lo han protegido porque
nosotros vivimos directamente de lo que
nos brinda el territorio y es por esa
razón que yo decía nosotros como copán
es si el territorio llega a desaparecer
estamos en riesgo también de que la
cultura cofán llegue a desaparecer y
también si la cultura cofán desaparece
lo mismo el territorio puede puede
desaparecer porque tenemos esa relación
estrecha desde la espiritualidad mismo y
nuestro día a día es cuidar el
territorio
obtener los alimentos de estos
territorios de la pesca de la casa y es
por eso que cuando hay una actividad
extractiva nos
afecta directamente a nuestra cultura y
pone en riesgo física y culturalmente a
nuestra vida como comunidades milenarias
y tenemos un entendimiento
finito sobre nuestro territorio que nos
brinda todo lo que necesitamos y hay
mucho que conocer sobre estos
territorios y es a eso lo que nosotros
le estamos apostando mediante esta
defensa ahora tenemos mejor de las leyes
ahora entendemos sobre nuestros derechos
a nivel internacional y eso es lo que
estamos también poniéndole más fuerza
para poder depender de estos territorios
sagrados es el legado de nuestros
ancestros álex no sé si vamos a poder
retomar la comunicación con el ex andra
por en todo caso yo quisiera preguntarle
si ha tenido usted la oportunidad de
trabajar pues estrechamente con él y
cuál es y cuál es la labor de las
mujeres de esa comunidad en defensa del
medio ambiente no
si nosotros alecsandro en mi persona
somos somos dos líderes jóvenes y
apoyamos a la comunidad sin angüe puntos
junto con la comunidad sin angüe nos
organizamos juntos hemos trabajado
durante estos últimos cinco años hemos
trabajado juntos
somos compañeros y hemos hemos estado
con el mismo sueño con el mismo
entendimiento de este proceso de lo que
hemos emprendido para defender estos
territorios
y es algo como maravilloso que el premio
ambiental goldman no reconozca nosotros
por toda esta lucha que nosotros hemos
llevado con la comunidad claro y con la
compañera del exacta y álex música pero
alexis gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en este espacio de france
24 directo américa nuevamente
felicitaciones y ojalá pues en su lucha
siga teniendo frutos siga teniendo
éxitos que al final pues es una es una
lucha una defensa que nos conviene a
todos porque al final es por nuestra
tierra por nuestro progreso planeta y
sobre todo nuestra región
latinoamericana también quiero dar las
gracias alexander narváez se que pues
por pro por problemas de comunicación no
pudo estar hablando con nosotros pero
pues conocimos un poco de lo que ha sido
esta lucha de la voz de al ex compañero
de ella gracias a la eximente por estar
con nosotros en directo américa un
abrazo
muchas gracias